molti artisti hanno lavorato su questa
tematica
qualcuno ha creato delle sculture che
sono dei veri e propri strumenti
musicali altri in altro modo
comunque ognuno di loro avuto il bisogno
di creare delle nuove forme e in quel
periodo ci fu un avvenimento che ha poi
segnato tutto ciò che è stata la mia
ricerca artistica
poiché il giorno mentre la lezione un
carro docente mi fece una proposta un po
insolita per l'orario soprattutto mi
chiese se avevo voglia di un amaro
lì per lì risposi di sì perché no non
sapendo se stesse scherzando meno e ad
un certo punto lui afferrò una lastra di
marmo la rupe accolse un frammento e mi
disse tieni assaggia qui c'è il sapore
del tempo allora questo aneddoto quanto
simpatico da raccontare in realtà ha
rivoluzionato tutto ciò che è stata la
mia ricerca artistica appunto e la
concezione di tempo e quindi di lì ho
capito che se avessi voluto misurarmi
con questi suoni primordiali avrei
dovuto farlo partendo dalle origini
della vita è incominciato a pensare ai
massi alle rocce ai marmi come dei
custodi che al loro interno conservano
quel processo lunghissimo naturale che
ci ha permesso di essere qui oggi
quindi non c'era alcun bisogno di creare
delle nuove forme perché era già tutto
lì all'interno della materia vi presento
la vita abbandonandosi alla morte si
restituisce alla terra depositando il
rumore della propria esistenza
in quest'opera quella appunto qui
presente
io associo alla forma della
sedimentazione della pietra un'onda
sonora complessa e questa è la
rappresentazione grafica appunto di un
suono complesso e quindi tramite questo
diagramma che ci riporta in dati tempo e
frequenza
abbiamo un suono possibile allora
quest'opera è probabilmente la più
concettuale di tutta una serie che poi
verrà in seguito e che è appunto al
pubblico di immaginare il suono quale
potrebbe essere il suono del tempo ma in
realtà quest'opera non è stata un punto
d'arrivo ma un punto di partenza poiché
di qui ho incominciato a lavorare su un
processo che riuscisse a tradurre
appunto l'immagine e il suono e grazie
alla collaborazione con un compositore
musicale ciò è stato reso possibile e
quindi ciò che avete ascoltato non è
altro che il rumore del tempo grazie
giocando un po con la varietà semantica
che la parola resilenza racchiude vorrei
farvi un progetto video e un video a
brevissimo poiché la mia intenzione era
quella di indurre nello spettatore uno
shock percettivo uno shock paragonabile
a quello che può derivare da una crisi
epilettica o da un terremoto
vedremo in un confronto si multa ioan
due scene appunto la registrazione as
pedaliera di un paziente colto da grande
male epilettico e scene del tutto nel
2011 il giappone con relativo tsunami
il terremoto più forte mai registrato in
giappone con magnitudo 9.0
ecco io penso che una crisi sia
necessaria per ristabilire un ordine che
il parà
si insinua che sono due fenomeni di
rilassamento
ok